you're a pro-independence party um the
polls though have shown
a bit of a slide in support for
independence over the last few days
uh noes now saying 53 yes 47 percent
uh have you backed the wrong horse here
the important part of this election and
what our manifesto talks about
is the recovery from the pandemic that's
the context that we're all living in
we are we desperately need a fair and
green recovery from the pandemic
creation of jobs upgrading of scotland's
homes and of course tackling the climate
crisis
what we're looking at in this election
is
the right of the scottish people to make
the decision about who makes those
decisions
so what we're looking at is asking for a
referendum
and given that we have had a
pro-independence majority
in parliament all this while and we
expect with the help of the scottish
greens
to have a pro-independence majority in
the next parliament as well
we think the people of scotland have the
right to decide who's going to be making
decisions about their recovery
is it the brexit territories in london
or is it a government in scotland
that we've actually elected but it isn't
a distinct
a distraction to be arguing about all
this because as you say there is so much
that that needs to be done after covert
um you know it
is it doesn't make sense to to use
political time
to go over this debate when there was
already a referendum we were told it was
a once in a generation event
democracy is a process of governing by
consent and as with any discussion on
consent
you need to check in regularly to see
whether people are still happy with the
direction of travel
it's very important to hold governments
to account and i think that
a lot of people in scotland have deep
concerns about the direction of travel
of the uk
the home office making life more
dangerous and
unpleasant for refugees cutting off
you know positive relationships with the
eu we seem to be alienating our nearest
neighbors we're
you know making fool of ourselves on the
international stage by calling
client people who concerned about the
climate crisis bunny huggers
the direction of travel at the uk is
deeply concerning and when boris johnson
thinks a recovery means
buying more nuclear weapons while at the
same time cutting public services
and seeing that nurses only get a one
percent pay rise i think it's very
reasonable
to ask the people of scotland do you
want to go along with this or do you
think we can do something better
do we think we can invest in a more
progressive in a fairer
more welcoming scotland is that the kind
of country you want to live in
well in terms of of being more
progressive one of the things that the
green parties embraced is something
called the yogyakarta
uh principles why has the green party
decided to support these
they have no standing in international
law and they've not been adopted
internationally in any treaty it's it's
about
trans rights isn't it and it's about
ensuring that the people
are not discriminated against because of
their gender
but there are a lot of people who have
many reservations about these principles
in particular
the scottish green party like green
parties all around the world is based
upon four principles
sustainability equality radical local
democracy
and we need to we need to make sure that
all humans have fair human rights
and that is a core part of what we
believe in we do not believe that trans
rights
are counter to women's rights all humans
have the same human rights
so of course when we when trans people
gain human rights or we make sure that
their human rights are respected
we don't take away the rights from
anyone else
a lot of women are concerned that if you
remove sex from from a lot of
documentation it jeopardizes the
provision of single sex spaces
that women have had to fight to to to
receive
and principle 31 of of the yogyakar
yatta principle
specifically says ensure that official
identity documents only include personal
information that's relevant reasonable
and necessary
and the registration of sex and gender
of a person identity documents such as
birth certificates
um passports etc i mean do you think
people in scotland
really don't want the sex of their child
recorded on a birth certificate
because that is relevant to
our investment changing so
we can get into the technical detail of
the interpretation of that
exact bit of wording in that document
your manifesto says
we are not talking about removing the
sex from a birth certificate
that is absolutely not what we're
talking about that law is meant to refer
to identity documents in countries where
your identity document has to have your
sex or gender on it so that you can
um access your civil rights we don't
have identity papers like that in
scotland
you don't have to use your birth
certificate to access civil rights
it is it's sort of one of those sort of
technical details but
we are absolutely not talking about
removing sex
from birth certificates that is not what
we're proposing at all
is the manifesto wrong then because it
does say that it will enshrine
the yogyakarta principles into scott's
law
the way you've interpreted that line of
that particular
that you read out there is not how we
would interpret that that is about
having the correct
gender on your documentation and that
means people should absolutely be able
to
identify their gender as they do already
on their passport
on their driver's license we're not
proposing to change that that's already
in law you can change the gender on your
passport or your driver's license to
make it match your self-identified
gender
we already have that in the uk we
already have the gender recognition act
that says that you know if you follow
the process
to get a gender recognition certificate
you can then also change the gender on
your birth certificate
that is what is in law and that was is
what we would like to see
kept the only change we would like to
see to that
is the change to the gender recognition
act to make that process a little bit
more humane to make it a little bit more
straightforward
at the moment it's very medicalized it's
very hostile it
means that a lot of people who would
really like to change their
documentation to make sure it's correct
don't don't do so because the process is
so unpleasant it's a very
very small change that we're wanting so
what insurance can you
so what reassurance can you give to
women in scotland that that under a
green party leadership
the provision of single sex services
won't be imp
implica implemented and that for example
if a woman goes to a rape center
she won't necessarily have to be
examined by somebody who was born a man
the scottish greens follow the advice of
women's groups in scotland
engender scotland rape crisis scotland
scotland's
all these charities and campaigns that
work for women's rights
we follow their guidance and their
advice and this is what we always do we
follow
the advice of experts and women's groups
we know that those
what what you fear there isn't isn't
what's going to happen
there is no concern about
women not giving consent for being
medically examined it's an absolute
with one of these whistle uh dog whistle
things
against trans right this sort of
terrible fear that a traumatized woman
would be re-traumatized by a rape crisis
center
that is not what rape crisis centers are
there for rape crisis centers are there
to support
women and trans people and anybody who's
been traumatized
in the circumstances but we also have to
respect the human rights of people who
work
in those centers and who people who give
those support services
so the we
absolutely are you know women would
have to women do absolutely have the
right to consent
um you know you need to have consent
before you can medically examine someone
there isn't a question around allowing
women to be unsafe and traumatized by
rape you know when they
at access rate crisis uh centers we
always follow the advice of rape crisis
scholar and then gender and other
women's groups
to make sure that women are properly
protected and that means trans women as
well
because trans women also need to be able
to access these services safely